we spend over a third of our lives in
the office
and the demands of modern working life
can often leave us feeling stressed and
depleted
so what can we do to create a happy
workspace
the natural world is full of curves
color and complexity and bringing all
this into the workplace can have a big
impact on our behavior and our mood
there are plenty of psychological
studies that reveal changes in the body
and brain when people view certain
colours
these changes can influence our
productivity our creativity stress
levels and much more
a recent report by human spaces showed
that two-thirds of people say they feel
happier when they walk into bright
office environments with yellow and blue
and green colors
think about what energy you want to
inject into your workspace and use color
to change the atmosphere
biophilia it's a fancy word with a
simple meaning
it's all about the connection we feel
with the natural world and helps explain
why being around plants and trees and
natural light can help us feel a bit
better in our daily lives
plants can fill and frame a space making
them feel wide and generous
studies show that bringing in a plant to
work can boost your productivity by 15
megacenters were set up to give people
who were going through cancer whether or
not it was a person with cancer
themselves or their family and friends a
place to come to to get help with the
challenges that cancer brings to their
lives psychological emotional and sort
of practical help
from the beginning at maggie's we always
knew the importance of
views connections to nature to be able
to allow
the distraction that being able to
see life and energy
outside a building was really very
important and we also knew that from the
experience that people have within
hospital we're often they're under strip
lights there's there's no distraction i
mean biophilia isn't a term that i think
people would come into the center would
talk about and sort of perhaps know
but what we do know is when they come in
the door they're immediately
there's a feeling that they have that
they they talk about that this is a
place that they feel that they want to
be and that they feel safe
and and that feeling is is in response
to the fact that they can see different
views into different sort of windows of
nature's trees moving um there's grapes
growing there's um
there's a pot outside where people can
go and pick mint to make their own tea
so it offers an element of control
within the environment a sense of of
peacefulness and
every time they come and they talk about
it being slightly different so there's a
sort of distraction and
an energy that comes from something
that's not static
researchers looked at two large
commercial offices in the uk and the
netherlands they found that plants
significantly increased workplace
satisfaction and self-reported levels of
focus
so why not knit down to the garden
center and add some greenery to your
desk
encouraging innovation isn't easy and
when it comes to buildings it means
doing things very differently here at
the francis crick institute in london
they've mixed up teams from different
disciplines right throughout the
building
the idea is that by bringing together
people with different specialties
amazing things can happen
and this is not the only building that's
recognized the value of mixing up
employees and organizations with
different disciplines
building 20 in mit was known as the
magical incubator
built near boston in 1942 it housed a
whole load of different laboratories
research groups and academic fields and
out of that collision came some of the
most groundbreaking developments in
science and technology
like the atomic clock
video games and gnome chomsky's
universal grammar
so if you're struggling to get through
the working day it might be worth
redesigning your office with well-being
in mind
because a happy and harmonious workspace
isn't something that just happens by
accident
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video